Hello! Welcome to "Michael's Better Business English".
This month we're looking at how to be tactful.
Now, tactful is a little bit of a difficult word.
Tactful means to be sensitive, to avoid hurting other people's feelings.
This is very important when you're giving bad news,...
...introducing a negative topic, or criticizing someone.
How can you do this?
Well, there are three steps to being tactful.
Step one, signal.
Signal means to signal to the listener some bad news or negative topic is coming.
And we use words like, "unfortunately," "regrettably," "with regret".
This lets the listener know something bad is coming and it helps them prepare.
Second, use some kind of qualifier.
A qualifier is some expression like "it seems" or "it appears".
This has a softening effect.
Third, use a modifier.
Modifiers are words like "slight" or "small".
For example, "We have a slight problem with the delivery."
These words make it feel less and underplay the negative topic.
So, being tactful is not easy.
But by using these three steps, you can do it.
Thank you and good luck.